- I think one of the most
common problems that people have
is not that they don't know
what to do to dramatically
move their life forward
in a substantial way.
You know exactly what
you need to do right now.
There's probably something
that you've been avoiding
like the plague,
but the problem is not that
you don't know what that is.
The problem is that you just
can't bring yourself to do it.
And that's the common
theme every single day is
that when you sit down to do this thing,
you feel a feeling and
it almost seems unfair
how potent this feeling of resistance is
because it's usually only
present when you think
about doing things that
are genuinely good for you.
So it's like, what's the deal with that?
Why does it seem like
life is set up that way?
Wouldn't it be better
if you just actually enjoyed
doing difficult things?
Wouldn't it be better
if you actually had the
motivation to be creative
or to write a paper or to do your taxes?
You probably want nothing more
than to be someone who genuinely enjoys
and looks forward to doing the
things that are good for you,
doing the things that empower you.
Recently I've been thinking.
There is one strategy that I have
that works every single time.
It always makes me do the
thing that I need to do.
It's not very flattering.
It's not very sexy.
We don't want to believe
that this is the answer.
And I feel like there's so much
self-improvement advice out there that
kind of ignores this
fundamental, not even tactic,
it's almost a fact of life.
And when we ignore this fact,
we'll try to do little
tips and tricks like, oh,
set a timer for five minutes
and just really try, try
really hard to do the work,
or try to think more positive
thoughts about your work.
But all those strategies,
they're kind of throw away strategies.
Yeah, they might work here or there,
but they get old really quick.
This strategy is nuclear.
So if you need to do one particular thing,
then if you do this, you will do it.
You will have no choice.
The solution is boredom.
Ironically that's also the problem.
The solution and the
problem are the same thing.
You don't wanna do that work
because it's so boring to your brain,
you want to gouge your eyes out.
All of these distractions
that you have around
sound so much more entertaining
than doing that thing.
So you always have a backdoor.
Why in hell would you write an essay
when you could be checking Instagram?
When you could be watching
YouTube videos like this one?
But the key realization is
that your brain doesn't see
objective entertainment values.
It's always relative.
A good analogy for this is
when you're spending all day
outside in the sun,
it's a super bright day,
and then you walk into
a dim room or a store,
that indoor space feels super dark.
You're like, I can't see
anything. What is this?
And then you see that weird
fake sun in your periphery
that starts to fade.
Everything looks weird and purplely.
And in a very similar way,
if you've been asleep for a couple hours
and you have to get up
and go to the bathroom,
you turn the lights on
and it's just blinding.
It's not that that
bathroom is any more bright
than it was before you went to bed
when you were brushing your teeth,
it's just that your brain
interprets things using contrasts.
It uses comparison.
So the key is to utterly
delete the back doors.
The key is to strip away
every single option,
to sit in a blank room with nothing in it,
no phone, nothing.
Eliminate your ability
to do anything other
than the thing that you need
to do and you will do it.
And now you might be thinking,
oh, it's not that simple.
I can just do nothing.
Well, you actually won't do nothing.
And there's studies to prove it.
There is a really weird study
published in Science in 2014.
That was a mouthful, it's not.
What am I, a freaking Neanderthal?
That's not a mouthful.
That was really hard to say.
So in this study,
they got a bunch of undergraduate students
to sit in a empty room by themselves
with absolutely nothing to do
and be alone with their own thoughts.
But they had one other option.
And that was to electrocute
themselves with a shocky button.
And it turns out 67% of the
men and 25% of the women
decided that electrocution
was better than boredom.
And some of the students
electrocuted themselves multiple times.
Even the ones that didn't
electrocute themselves
either strongly considered
it or at least lamented as
to how miserable the quiet
time was and how boring it was.
You might have heard
about this study before,
but I think it's a great example
as to how much human
beings dislike being bored.
And so the reason why solitary
confinement is considered one
of the least humane forms
of torture imaginable.
There's this ancient
torture method where they
basically just throw somebody
down a hole under the castle
and forget about them
for their entire lives.
Number 15, the oubliette.
The last thing you'd
want after stealing a cup
of buckwheat is to end up in
one of these mother (bleep).
That sounds terrible
because it's so boring.
If you were put in an empty
room with nothing to do
except one thing,
unless that thing is
like chop off your hand,
you're probably gonna do that thing.
And while you're doing that thing,
that thing will feel so
much more entertaining
than doing nothing.
So you have to ask yourself,
what are you constructing
your life around?
How are you structuring things?
Are the things that you're
supposed to do entertaining
in comparison to the things
that you use as distractions?
Because the larger the disparity,
the more agonizing that thing will be.
And you'll find very quickly
that if you delete distractions
as an option, it works right away.
It's insane.
This isn't like some dopamine detox
that you gotta do over
weeks and months and years,
although that will help
you get used to finding
the entertainment value
in difficult things.
This is something that works right away
because your brain needs to to survive.
It hates feeling bored.
So it will make whatever
your only option is
as entertaining as it needs to.
I even have personal evidence for this.
One of the most productive, social,
and energetic times in my entire life
is when I was living in
a little 900 square foot
basement suite in the middle of suburbia
with absolutely nothing
to do except edit videos.
So here's Alex looking in
the pantry for stuff to eat.
These guys cooked us
our only good meal that
we've had in several days.
And basically this whole
video is basically just
to show off what we have going
on in our fridge right now.
(roommates laughing)
Ketchup, a little bit of
milk, some Korean honey.
Three pickles, salsa, and water.
I was absolutely broke.
And to edit these videos that I had to do
for my very few corporate
freelance videography clients.
I was sitting on an
upside down laundry hamper
because I couldn't afford an office chair,
but this was deeply motivating to me.
Although I did live with my friend, Alex,
he was hardly ever around
so I had these long periods
of loneliness,
but that sting of
loneliness made me social.
It made me make plans.
It made me seek opportunities.
My lack of money made me seek money.
And most importantly,
the lack of things to do in there,
the lack of distractions that
I surrounded myself with,
made me extremely bored,
bored enough that editing
videos and being highly creative
and doing what I love actually
felt entertaining as well.
So there's a perfect example
of my environmental conditioning
helping facilitate a mindset
of creativity and
attitude of productivity.
It's because I had very few other options.
So in summary,
if you have something
you need to do right now,
then eliminate all your back
doors, turn off your phone,
remove your gaming PC from your room,
remove your Xbox.
Auto hide the toolbar
so when you're thinking
of the next word to write,
you don't look at Safari and
automatically click on it.
And in living life this way
and treating productivity this way,
it's not that you're going to
live a less entertaining life.
In fact, you might find
it far more entertaining
and fulfilling and empowering
than you ever knew possible.
And if you're looking for an excellent way
to have more stamina throughout the day
so that when you are
actually doing the things
that you need to do, you
can do it for longer,
then it will probably help to feel good,
mentally and physically,
using today's video
sponsor, Athletic Greens.
You guys already know that AG1
is by far my favorite
supplement on the planet.
It is an integral part
of my morning routine
and it makes me feel so
good throughout the day,
I almost can't believe it.
AG1 supports your energy, focus,
gut health, immunity, mental clarity,
without the need to take
multiple products or pills.
And I think the reason I feel
so good while I'm taking it
is because there's almost
no competing with the amount
of vitamins and nutrients in
just one scoop of this stuff.
And the fact that it's
sourced from real food,
real superfoods condensed
down into a bioavailable form
means that your body can actually use it.
It absorbs it really well.
So you're not just urinating it out.
So if you guys are interested
in joining me in participating
in this very simple
health optimization habit
that I've been doing for
around two years now,
then use my link in the description below
and you'll also get a year's supply
of their vitamin D3 and K2 complex,
which I also have every single morning,
as well as five AG1 travel
packs with your first purchase.
So take advantage of that link below.
Optimize your health, feel fantastic.
And as usual, have a great time.
If you liked this video,
then if you actually hit the like button,
that's a huge help
because the video will rank better,
shoving my bald head into
other people's homepages,
helping them out, which also helps me out.
So it is a win-win for everybody involved.
If you've seen my face a couple of times
and you like my videos,
consider subscribing and
hitting up the Instagram.
Sometimes I post some
memey silly shit on there.
And it's just fun.
Other than that, though,
thank you so much for watching
and we'll catch you in the next video.
(gentle music)